I
[Music]
welcome back I'm Steve Brunton and this
is another video in our lecture series
on understanding Co vid 19 through the
lens of control theory and today I'm
going to specifically talk about the
importance of measuring our system of
taking of sensing and measuring our
system to make better control decisions
and to inform better models so in the
last few lectures we've talked a lot
about this overarching control diagram
how we have our disease system this
unstable spread of this disease as it
goes through a population and our
efforts to take actions to control this
spread in this case to bring it below
the healthcare capacity and in this
lecture what I'm going to point out is
the importance of measurements in this
system okay so this is this large
feedback control diagram that I'm
showing is predicated on the
availability of accurate fast
measurements so measurements sensor
measurements are the lifeblood of
feedback control and they are what allow
us to kind of achieve the high
performance and robustness that control
systems are able to you know to attain
even in unstable systems
okay so sensor measurements are critical
we need especially fast sensor
measurements and so in this video I'm
going to talk about a little bit more
detail on why we need sensors why we
need them to be fast the issues of time
delays what types of sensing strategies
are out there and how they fit into this
larger control diagram okay so if you
can't tell I think measurements are
absolutely critical for us to be able to
effectively suppress the spread of this
disease and to keep it suppressed and
under control we need effective
measurements we need extensive and
accurate and fast measurements okay so
there's a great article in the I Triple
E spectrum I encourage you to check this
out where they talk about different
control strategies and how control can
help us understand and control this this
spread one of the concerns people have
so we've been
kind of suppressing the spread of this
disease by global widespread efforts of
you know social distancing no handshakes
limiting large gatherings stage shelter
and place laws things like that okay so
a massive global effort to keep this
disease suppressed what people are
worried about is that once we start to
lift those restrictions once we start to
open up and to go back to work and to go
back to school and go back about our
daily lives people are worried that this
might have a resurgence this disease
might rebound and we might have to go
into quarantine again and again and
again and that's a you know that's a
pretty big concern we don't want to do
that we don't want to keep doing this
on/off bang-bang control and one of the
only ways that we can you know at least
from a control theory perspective
prevent that kind of course control is
through more effective sensor
measurements okay so so one alternative
is to use feedback control to measure
the system and measure the system
extensively enough and quickly enough
that you can essentially maintain this
this level that's below the health care
capacity without doing this this big
bang bang control that might last months
or even years okay but to do this
feedback control strategy to enact this
this feedback control you need to have
enough measurements of your system that
are accurate enough and fast enough to
be to be useful in real time okay so I
also want to point out these
measurements are not used alone we're
going to use these measurements with our
models so I want to remind you this is a
great New York Times article comparing
five coronavirus models we have lots of
models of the spread of this disease but
all of those models give different
predictions and that's okay we know that
our models are imperfect but they're
still useful for control but I just want
to point out if you have models that are
this different this kind of model
diversity and uncertainty we absolutely
need to also be taking measurements
extensive measurements of our system
to pin these models and to correct our
feedback control that is kind of
balancing our models and our
measurements okay so that's where we're
talking about is essentially you know we
know that we have imperfect models we
are not exactly sure how effective our
controllers are going to be so we
absolutely rely on our measurements of
our system to see how the actual system
is responding okay so what are some of
the types of measurements and tests that
we can take in this system and there's
there's a lot at our disposal so one
thing you can do is test for symptoms
you know does someone have a fever you
know do they do they have the symptoms
of coronavirus another type of test you
can test for antibodies in in the
patient so this is called serological
testing for example you know what
proportion of citizens in Manhattan have
anti-bodies meaning that they have
already had or currently have you know
this this virus you can also test
directly for this RNA from the virus to
see if that is currently in in the
patient so there's all kinds of tests
that you can do and some of these are
faster and some of these are slower than
others so for example you know in in
some Southeast Asian countries there are
apps on your phone so you take your
fever twice a day and you enter those
numbers into this app and it goes into a
central database so that they can kind
of track the progression of symptoms
over time so symptoms might be might be
really fast to measure antibodies and
RNA those take longer
right you have to maybe measure some you
know swab and send it to a lab and and
maybe there's a queue so there are
different time delays for these
different measurements now implicit in
all of this there is a bigger time delay
which is so I'm gonna point out that
time delays are a big problem here there
is a time delay of incubation so when
you catch the virus there is some period
maybe before you express symptoms and
antibodies and so on and so forth and so
those time delays make this are really
really hard
problem and it motivates having a larger
sensor network there's also issues with
statistical bias so if you only test
people who are sick and who have severe
symptoms who go to the hospital you're
gonna get a massively skewed sample of
what the actual population statistics
look like and that's a huge problem so
we know that there are many asymptomatic
carriers who have had kovat 19 and
didn't show symptoms and if you only
test people in the hospital you get a
massively skewed number of all of the
important parameters that you need to
use when you're modeling this system
okay so it's super important to get to
test sick and healthy people to take
random testing of the population one
thing that they actually do our sewage
tests I think this is super interesting
is that you can actually measure the
sewage output from a city and you get
this very coarse measurement of kind of
how that city you know maybe you're
testing for antibodies or RNA or
something like that
and a lot of these tests are kind of
standard you know they teach these in
biology classrooms in colleges across
the country the equipment exists this is
you know standard stuff it's just you
know to ramp this up at a scale of an
entire country you know is very
challenging to do this kind of taste
testing in mass okay good so you know I
feel very fortunate to live in the
Pacific Northwest where there are huge
efforts ongoing actually a lot of this
has been funded by the Gates Foundation
and others there are institutes like the
Institute for Health metrics and
evaluation the Institute for disease
modeling that are focused on modeling
these kinds of disease systems and
health systems and modeling the data
that you get from these kinds of sensor
networks there's also the Seattle flu
study which was already in place to
measure the progression of flu as it
spreads across a network of people in a
city and recently they have ramped
and combined with other organizations to
create this Seattle coronavirus
assessment network which essentially is
measuring all of these hard to measure
variables to try to quantify the you
know the the nuances of the spread of
coronavirus in in Seattle so I think
that's really cool and this is really
important to have these kinds of
modeling and sensing networks already in
place so I think one of the reasons that
Southeast Asia has been pretty effective
in their efforts to contain kovat 19 is
because years earlier they had the SARS
scare they were really worried that SARS
was gonna do exactly what ko vid 19 is
doing now and so they put in lots of
infrastructure and sensor networks and
surveillance networks because of SARS
because they knew that this this could
happen and so they had that
infrastructure in place and that's
something that you know is absolutely
vital if you really want good effective
kind of responsive control over your
system you need to be measuring more
than just how many people are sick every
day in a city okay that's not enough we
need more detailed measurements in time
okay and you know so I've already shown
you lots about the models we use for
these systems and the models we use to
turn a design control strategies but all
of these parameters the recovery rate
the infection rate all of the parameters
of these models and how they affect
different population groups different
age groups different socio-economic
groups you know from city to city these
parameters are different and under
different social distancing and
different control strategies all of
these parameters are different that's
what we're trying to control but you
need extensive and accurate measurements
to understand what these parameters are
and how effective your control
strategies are so I think that's really
important you absolutely need you know
extensive measurements to get good
models to make effective control
decisions especially since we have time
delays we need our models to be as good
as possible and so we need all of the
information
that we can get our hands on so I've
already talked a lot about time delays
both in this video and in others in my
mind when I think about the spread of
coronavirus and our efforts kind of
within the US and internationally I am
you know constantly thinking about time
delays because as a control theorist I
know that these are some of the
trickiest issues that you ever have to
deal with in a control system is when
there are time delays between what you
measure and and what actually is
happening in the system or between when
you think you've enacted a control
strategy and when it actually becomes
effective or when you think that you
know someone is showing symptoms and
when they actually got infected and
infected others time delays are really
really tricky and so I think that we
absolutely have to be thinking about our
surveillance networks knowing what we
know about time delays and how they
affect robust performance so a lot of
times if you make control decisions and
you have time delays in your system you
can get unstable responses where you're
kind of doing the wrong control at the
wrong time because there's a delay and
your system can go unstable that's a
really big issue and so you know one
strategy when you have these big time
delays is to have good models that
predict where your system is going to be
you make decisions based on that and
then on a slower supervisory time scale
you make corrections based on the
measurements you're taking and those
measurements can improve the model which
improves the kind of aggressiveness with
which you can make fast control
decisions so the measurements are good
for both the modeling and for the
feedback and really are are quite
essential there's already discussions
about software you know to track our
people you know properly socially
distancing to collect that information
you know this is a pretty simple
computer vision problem now actually I
mean this is this is commercial
there's also discussions about whether
or not we should have you know thermal
scans and airports and in train stations
and places so can we measure
does someone have a fever in real time
okay and this brings up a lot of privacy
concerns so you know having an extensive
surveillance network and having
measurements of your system is critical
for good feedback control but there are
big privacy concerns do we want to ramp
up a massive surveillance network that's
something that you know is a real
concern and something that we really
need to think about I mean we all are
carrying you know essentially a big
suite of sensors and it tells us where
we are and how close to people we are
when we go to crowded areas you know
there is a tremendous amount of data
that could be tapped and there are big
societal questions that we have to ask
and answer about how to use that data
responsibly whether we do how much of it
to use things like that those are you
know bigger than any one of us can can
decide okay good so you know I hope I've
kind of convinced you of how important
this measurements and sensors are in
this feedback loop and how we can really
only get the kind of control performance
we need if we have fast accurate sensors
there's a lot of talk now about contact
tracing which basically means if you
have a sick person can you go and trace
all of the people they've been in
contact with and then test them and try
to contain and do a much more isolated
quarantine that way this is also again
happening in lots of other countries
around the world to varying degrees of
effectiveness this is what a lot of
people call boot leather epidemiology or
boots on the ground it takes a lot of
people a lot of resources to go do that
detective work of contact tracing that's
another kind of sensor network that we
can deploy at a finer more granular
level okay good
so I hope I've given you some some
feeling for how hard of a problem this
is there are you know ethical societal
concerns there are technological
concerns there are practical concerns
about the time delays that your sensors
will inevitably have in this
control architecture but I do firmly
believe that if you want to do a good
job you need to be extensively measuring
your system all right thank you